THE STORY THAT I’M SO GLAD
WE’RE TELLING.
THANK YOU, BILL.
NEARLY 90 DAYS AFTER THE
PRESIDENT PUT THE VICE
PRESIDENT IN CHARGE OF HANDLING
THE BORDER CRISIS KAMALA HARRIS
HAS STILL YET TO GO.
DOZENS OF HOUSE REPUBLICANS
HAVE WRITTEN THE PRESIDENT
DEMANDING THE REMOVAL OF KAMALA
HARRIS FROM THAT ROLE AND
DEMOCRATIC TEXAS CONGRESSMAN
HENRY CUELLAR WHO TOLD "THE
FAULKNER FOCUS" LAST WEEK HE
ASKED THE VICE PRESIDENT TO
VISIT.
SAYS HE IS STILL TRYING AND
STILL WAITING.
>> I HAVE NOT HEARD FROM HER
OFFICE.
I HAVE TALKED TO THE WHITE
HOUSE.
MY WHITE HOUSE CONTACT BUT I
HAVE NOT HEARD FROM HER AND
AGAIN WE’RE READY TO HELP HER
IN ANY WAY.
THIS IS NOT OUR FIRST RODEO.
WE SAW THIS 2014 UNDER
PRESIDENT OBAMA, 2019 UNDER
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
THERE ARE PEOPLE JUST COMING IN.
IF WE DON’T TAKE THOSE
INCENTIVES AWAY THEY WILL KEEP
COMING.
THAT’S PLAIN AND SIMPLE.
>> Harris: RESPECT TO
REPRESENTATIVE CUELLAR.
THIS ISN’T LIKE IT WAS IN 2014.
IT HASN’T LOOKED LIKE THIS IN
MORE THAN 20 YEARS.
THE ARIZONA ATTORNEY GENERAL.
GREAT TO HAVE YOU ON THE
PROGRAM.
I WANT TO GET YOUR REACTION TO
WHAT WE’RE LEARNING AND FINALLY
HEARING WORDS THAT WE NEVER
WANTED TO HEAR AND NEVER
THOUGHT WE WOULD.
THEY’RE DONE AND OVERWEMD, THE
BORDER AGENTS.
>> IT IS SO DISAPPOINTING,
HARRIS.
BECAUSE THESE FOLKS ARE TRYING
TO PROTECT US, TRYING TO
PROTECT THE ENTIRE COUNTRY AND
IF YOU TALK TO THEM THEY WILL
TELL YOU THAT NOT ONLY DO THEY
FEEL OVERWHELMED BUT
DEMORALIZED.
THEY WILL BE PUNISHED FOR DOING
THEIR JOB AND TOLD TO IGNORE
THE LAW AND LET PEOPLE GO.
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICIALS.
ONE OF OUR LAWSUITS WE DEPOSED
THE INTERIM DIRECTOR OF ICE IN
PHOENIX.
IT IS A DANGER TO OUR COMMUNITY
AND WORRIED ABOUT THE IMPACT IT
WILL HAVE WHEN YOU DON’T DEPORT
PEOPLE WHO ARE FELONS OR PEOPLE
BEING INCENTIVIZED TO COME OVER
HERE.
A THREAT TO ALL OUR COMMUNITIES
AND DEMORALIZING TO ALL OF THIS.
>> Harris: I WANT TO REMIND
EVERYBODY ABOUT THE LAWSUITS.
I HEAR YOU SAY YOU ARE SUING.
CATCH US UP ON HOW THAT’S
UNFOLDING.
>> IN OUR LAWSUIT SUED THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION FOR PAUSE
ON DEIMPORTANT PAITIONTATIONS
WHICH NOW HAS BECOME PERMANENT
WE’RE WAITING FOR A FEDERAL
JUDGE’S DECISION.
SHE WAS HARD ON THE QUESTIONING.
SHE RECOGNIZED THERE ARE PEOPLE
IN STATE AND FEDERAL CUSTODY
BEING RELEASED IN OUR
COMMUNITIES AND THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION HAD NO ANSWER
WHY THEY ARE DOING THAT.
THAT IS A THREAT AND DANGER TO
OUR COMMUNITY.
WE’RE WAITING FOR THAT DECISION
AND TWO NEW LAWSUITS GOING ON.
ONE REGARDING THE PUBLIC CHARGE
RULE AND COUPLE OTHER A.G.s
PETITIONED THE SUPREME COURT TO
PROTECT THAT RULE THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATIONS TO STOP
ALLOWING BENEFITS THAT ARE
COSTING THE AMERICAN TAXPAYERS
AND INCENTIVIZING ILLEGAL
BORDER CROSSINGS AND THE LAST
ONE IS ENVIRONMENTAL CRISIS
BEING CREATED BY ALL THE PEOPLE
CROSSING THE BORDER.
>> Harris: I WANT TO TELL
EVERYBODY THERE IS ANOTHER
THING THAT’S HAPPENING.
AXIOS IS REPORTING THAT
PRESIDENT BIDEN WILL END A
TRUMP ERA RULE TO MANDATE
SENDING FAMILY UNITS BACK TO
MEXICO.
I WANT YOU TO TALK ABOUT IT NOW.
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL BRNOVICH
OF ARIZONA NOW, WHAT IS THIS
RULE?
HOW WILL IT CHANGE WHEN IT GOES
AWAY?
HOW WILL WE FEEL THIS?
>> TITLE 42 IS A FEDERAL
STATUTE.
WHAT HAS HAPPENED DURING THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION THEY TRIED
TO LIMIT THE PEOPLE COMING
ACROSS THE BORDER WHERE THEY
COULD DO THESE EXPEDITED
REMOVALS BASED ON THE FACT THEY
COULD BE A PUBLIC HEALTH THREAT
TO PEOPLE IN THE COUNTRY.
WE HAVE SEEN THIS LAST YEAR
WITH COVID THAT WE WERE TOLD AS
AMERICANS THAT WE CAN’T GATHER,
WE HAVE TO SOCIAL DISTANCE, WE
CAN’T GO TO WORKPLACES AND YET
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION NOW
HAS THESE DETENTION CENTERS.
1200 ROOM HOTEL IN ARIZONA
WHERE PEOPLE ARE CRAMPED
TOGETHER AND BEING RELEASED
INTO OUR COMMUNITY.
THERE IS THIS POTENTIAL THREAT
TO THE PUBLIC HEALTH AND SAFETY
AND THE ADMINISTRATION HAS SOME
DISCRETION.
WHAT I THINK WE’VE SEEN IS THE
OLD POTTERY BARN RULE.
IF YOU BREAK IT, YOU BUY IT.
I WOULD SUBMIT TO ALL YOUR
VIEWERS THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION IS BREAKING AND
DESTROYING IT AND IT IS UP TO
THEM TO FIX IT AND BY THEM
CREATING ALL THESE INCENTIVES
OR MAKING IT HARDER FOR ICE TO
DO ITS JOB ENCOURAGING MORE
PEOPLE TO COME HERE.
SYSTEM IS BEING OVERWHELMED AND
CARTELS ARE TAKING ADVANTAGE OF
THE SITUATION.
>> Harris: FROM OUR REPORTER,
NO FEAR OF BEING CAUGHT AS THE
SMUGGLERS COME IN AND CARRYING
ALL OF THESE ILLEGALS AND OUR
GUYS ARE PROTECTING THE